[Music]
she's got this beautiful dress on makeup
done hair did nails done everything did
sorry I couldn't help myself you fancy
huh you fancy H Brandon and Mary get
married despite their doubts I promise
you that you will never have to worry
about me abandoning you I love you more
than anything and it was a nice ceremony
and until it started raining beetles I'm
looking over and there's like this fog
rolling
in oh my
gosh and I realized that's not a fog
that's that's a lot of bugs y'all I have
never seen anything like this in my life
what does it mean is it a bad Omen is it
a good omen this looks
bad there's hundreds of bugs everywhere
over here
Jee plus Danielle kicks the 90-day crew
out of her house after Johan leaves her
and tries to take their dog with him I
want everyone out of my house now I want
everyone out of my house now I want
everyone out of my house now all of you
get out get out let's get into
it hey 90day fans famam It's Mia for
those who celebrate you know it is
Thanksgiving week I wish you the best
time with your loved ones if you're
hanging out Solo or working make sure
you at least enjoy some good food okay
before we get into Mary and Brandon
saying I do let's talk about Johan
[Music]
saying finally my husband wants to leave
me at the happiest time of the year yeah
let's rewind and get into how this
latest argument started last episode we
started a toy drive online where people
from the US were able to buy gifts from
from a wish list and we would pay for
the shipping cost while rapping gifts
for the kids in the neighborhood
Danielle asked Johan for the money he's
supposed to contribute to the house each
month why she chose to ask him while
they're trying to spread Christmas Joy
your guess is as good as mine it was an
argument waiting to
happen
okay so we're all clear 75,000 Dominican
pesos is about
1,319 and 26 to be exact I Googled it
that's a lot of money for a man who
barely has a job last time we checked he
was collecting debt from
people in this moment it's like she's
asking him for something she knows he
doesn't have and what's unfortunate is
that it doesn't even seem like Johan is
out here trying to get it yes I
understand that opportunities in his
environment are limited It's hard out
there but he's not even trying to make
it work with Danielle he's making it
more clear every week that he just wants
to be taken care
of Welcome to adulthood Johan you have
to pay for stuff and in many cases stuff
you don't want to pay pay for yes it's a
blessing to be able to afford things but
if we could have those same things and
not have to pay for them I think most of
us would choose the
latter ain't easy you going say that
again
your
he looks tired and Danielle should be
drained too she's been trying to force
Johan into becoming a man that he's just
not and I understand it's easy to fall
in love with potential but the reality
is he doesn't meet her standards he
doesn't even want to meet her
standards fast forward to this week's
episode Danielle and Johan put the drama
aside for a moment to go deliver the
gifts to the kids in the neighborhood my
first Christmas living in Dominican
Republic has turned out to be the worst
Christmas of my
[Music]
life here we go here that's for you baby
I'm trying to hold it together for the
kids but this is really really hard to
do you know Danielle's costume made me
realize how much we don't appreciate the
elves more than likely she did all the
hard work putting this toy drive
together yet the kids are like
Santa
Santa if it wasn't for the elf the toy
wouldn't
exist these two get back in the car and
after being on a little high from seeing
the kids so
happy
they start to talk about their
relationship and these two turn into the
grumpiest Santa and elf I've ever seen
okay Johan tells Danielle that he wants
to take off his Santa costume before he
goes to his moms so they return to the
apartment Johan changes and he starts to
pack his clothes o that's when it gets
real
Petty what what are you going to do with
his clothes Danielle just let him take
them why is she buying him so many
clothes that money could have been going
to the rent or it could have been for
things in the house Johan's closet is
looking pretty fool for him not to have
any money once again it's giving spoiled
teenage son
Danielle lets the clothes go but then
she tells him not to take the
[Music]
hangers he wants to call somebody else
selfish and cheap but it's looking like
he married Danielle just to use her and
he's admitted to not wanting to pay any
bills okay aside from that I will say
it's clear that Danielle doesn't want
him to leave first it's the clothes then
it's the hangers and now it's the don't
dare take all those Yankee hats you
on no no no no no no no no no no no
those are mine no you're not leaving
with them no enough enough girl just let
him go
me you're not going anywhere with my dog
or my house you're not going
anywhere you're not going anywhere with
my
dog no no no no no you're not going
anywhere with my dog youan what poor dog
he's caught in the middle of his parents
drama and toxicity just like a child
would be I wonder would something like
this affect him y'all know dogs can
become come emotionally traumatized too
yanan no give me the dog give me the
dog you're not human I want everyone out
of my house now I want everyone out of
my house now I want everyone out of my
house now all of you get out get
out all she had to say was I don't want
you to leave but it became about the
clothes then the hangers then the hats I
can understand the dog now that was sad
luckily he didn't take Gizmo because
she's going to need that unconditional
love tonight and next week it finally
looks like she's officially tired of
this relationship I've learned some
things over the course of the last week
and I don't want anything to do with Yan
I have been wearing rose-colored glasses
this entire time I think that the Yan
that I was seeing and was believing was
there was never actually in front of me
what did he do now I can't wait to find
out all right let's get into Brandon and
Mary at the beginning of the episode
it's the morning of their wedding day
Mary seems to be in a good mood even
though last night she was questioning if
she even wanted to marry Brandon
following an argument they had because
he's been so focused on his video gam
after our fight there's definitely some
awkwardness some tension between me and
Mary got everything need help with
anything going to call
Lola last night when Mary and my mom got
back from church it was very tense and
we just went straight to bed Mary leaves
the house with her grandmother to go get
ready for the ceremony and she admits as
she's heading to her wedding that she
still has doubts even though Brandon's
mom really helps me to understand how
much I loved him I feel like I'm not
ready to marry him cuz he still didn't
reassure me that I can trust him to be
man enough to be a father and my future
[Music]
husband knowing what we know now about
them Beatles those words take on a new
meeting but in this moment Mary tells
her grandmother her wedding is going to
be sad because her grandfather won't be
in attendance he's working at least
that's what was said back at the house
Brandon and his mom are getting dressed
and she cuts straight to the chase with
him you're getting
married and it is for life you're going
to be a father this is it you know man
up while she tells him to man up she
also tells him she believes he can do it
which seems to be exactly what Brandon
needs to hear I know you have the
ability to do this I have seen you do
things for her with her because of her
at the age of
23 than any of the men I ever dated all
the way up into their
40s it's just going to take some effort
on your
part thank you that that means a
lot sometimes you just need to hear
someone say I believe in you and mean it
especially a parent that can do wonders
for your confidence fast forward to the
wedding oh yeah by the way the mayor is
marrying them which took Brandon by
surprise honestly I don't know who I was
expecting but definitely not the mayor
well maybe if you got off those video
games
Brandon I'm just kidding actually no I'm
not I know that our love is real so I'm
going to marry him the ceremony starts
and Mary looks beautiful as she walks
down the aisle she's got this beautiful
dress on makeup done hair did I'm just
like wow like to
this this is such a beautiful woman
right
here am I really getting married to
her yes you are For Better or For Worse
they exchange vows as Mary tears up and
Brandon looks onto her with so much
pride and I promise you that you will
never have to worry about me abandoning
you I see my future with you I love you
more than
anything I just want you to know that I
love you so much and I know that we're
fighting a lot whoever this lady is
right here she is so happy for them she
has such a sweet smile I love you so
much and I know that we're fighting a
lot but I I want to spend my life my
whole life with you forever
Mary do you take Brandon to be your
lawful weed
husband I
do Brandon do you take
Mary to be your lawful weding wife I do
after the ceremony Mary says something
to Brandon that is a bit concerning but
we are going to keep it moving because
it is their special day I feel so happy
because here in the Philippines there's
so divorced and he doesn't have a way to
leave
me I would never leave you for anything
in this world it sounds cute now but
just because you can't get a divorce
doesn't mean he won't leave and it
definitely doesn't mean you won't be
miserable but I'm hoping to Brandon's
mom's point they work on their issues
individually like Mary and her fear of
abandon
so they can become a healthier
couple am I doing it
right everything was just absolutely
[Music]
stunning I came here with a chip on my
shoulder towards Mary and in the course
of being here my perception has
changed and the willingness that she has
to making this marriage with my son a su
success means more to me than anything
in the world his mom she's a real one I
like her okay the reception begins and
you start to hear Brandon Mary and his
mom complain about the bugs there's a
lot of bugs they're trying to get on you
these bugs are insane they're
everywhere but it's an outdoor wedding
there's food there are lights of course
you can expect bugs but what comes next
is like something out of a movie I'm
looking over and there's like this fog
rolling
in oh my
gosh and I realized that's not a fog
that's that's a lot of bugs o if I was
at that wedding I would have embarrassed
myself everyone's freaking out over the
bugs miss lady isn't smiling anymore
what
are there's hundreds of bugs
everywhere
okay holy it's getting worse it's not
getting better this is this is
insane God you okay Bobby over here nope
couldn't be me I would have been running
until there was no bug in sight does
anybody know what this is is this
typical in the Philippines there's
always somebody who knows random stuff
like this in the comments speak up up my
initial thought was are the ancestors
trying to say something because it
doesn't look like they're happy but then
I Googled what does a scarab beetle
symbolize yes I am that person who will
look deep into things and according to
google in Egypt the Scarab Beatles were
important symbols of rebirth and renewal
as well as good luck and Fortune H so it
might look like a bad Omen but in
actuality it might be a good one or it
could be nothing and the bugs were just
hungry and they flew toward the light
time will tell speaking of time next
week Brandon's mom has a panic attack
because the Beatles wouldn't go away
they said this is our party now we got
swarmed by millions of bugs my mom's
having like a panic
attack this is getting worse and worse
and worse look at me oh they're all over
you that is crazy
all right 90day fans fam thanks for
hanging with me next week there will not
be a recap because of Thanksgiving but
I'll be back the following week with all
you need to know all right make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next
time